I've seen this raw strength only once
before it scared me enough that
[Music]
that was a scene from Star Wars the last
Jedi of which is about to unseat Beauty
and the Beast as the biggest film of
2017
along with blockbusters the year has
seems the release of some great smaller
films independent productions that often
lack the marketing budgets to help them
break through fortunately fandango's
managing editor Erik Davis is here to
share some of his picks for the most
over looks looked films of these I love
this Erik I love this segment these
smaller movies deserve a bigger
spotlight on them and you might not
agree with all your choices but let's
start off here the first one is brawl in
cellblock 99 of Vince Vaughn that we've
never really seen oh and you know that a
few minutes into the movie with Vince
Vaughn is destroying a car with his
fists this is not wedding crashers Vince
Vaughn this is fist destroying Vince
Vaughn he plays a man who works for the
wrong guy gets thrown in prison finds
himself in a predicament predicament in
order to get out of that predicament he
has to go to some dark and nasty places
maybe not necessarily the movie you want
to watch on New Year's Day with your
whole family but if you're looking to
curl up on a cold night with a gnarly
little prison drama that's like the
midnight movie version of Liam Neeson is
taken I say see all right gnarly drama
starring popular dudes in roles where
they're unrecognizable similar thing
happening in good time which stars
Robert Pattinson outstanding Robert
Pattinson it is a travesty that this man
is not being nominated for awards I
think if there is a single most
overlooked performance in 2017 it is
Robert Pattinson in good time he plays a
delinquent who robs a prank with his
brother brother gets caught he then has
to go and save his brother he spends the
rest of the movie doing what I love
about it is the pacing it's got this
relentless pace to it I was talking to a
woman yesterday he said I'm in the mood
right now for an edge of your seats
thriller that's got some twists on it
that's gonna take me for a ride I said
see good time and you'll thank me later
next one though got savaged
by critics valerian in the city of a
thousand planets luc besson who's done
some really interesting visual movies in
the past not known for logical
storytelling but you liked this one I
did liked it you know and the Holly
Reporter just put on this on their worst
list ad
we got about on Twitter I was like
you're out of bounds at thr this is a
big bold colorful science fiction and I
love luc besson I think he is a mad
genius I think there are pockets of
brilliance in this film and what I love
about him is he always puts strong women
at the heart of his movies from the
professional to the Fifth Element to La
Femme Nikita to Lucy and so I'd like to
support that and I think guys like this
I mean this is a labor of love for any
put its own money into this may be
gorgeous I will say that it's beautiful
and you know in this day and age where
everything is a franchise or a sequel or
a rebooting you get something fresh like
this even though it is based on an
existing comment from the comic muse
sixties it's it's nice it's refreshing
and he got Rihanna
he said it took him this long he's
always wanted to make it but the
technology wasn't there and now it
finally exactly if you like films like
The Fifth Element I said this is right
in your will yeah Luc Besson's a pioneer
of sorries okay patty-cakes
yes coming-of-age story about a young
female rapper yeah yeah well and this
one you know it doesn't it's not about a
real-life hip-hop crew like Straight
Outta Compton it doesn't star realize
hip-hop artists like eight-mile and
Eminem but it really much is like the
female version of eight-mile except it's
not set in Detroit it's set in the
swamps of Jersey and that Springsteen
you would say and it features this great
performance from Danielle McDonald who's
actually Australian and you wouldn't
think it the way she rocks a Jersey
accent in this movie it's got a great
original hip-hop if you are fan of
movies about hip hop that have a lot of
hip hop in it like I am yeah if you are
from New Jersey they do not make a lot
of movies about New Jersey please write
see this film the florida project a 95
on Rotten Tomatoes yeah yeah this is a
sweet and heartbreaking movie it's about
kids but it's not for kids and so I
think for adults sometimes it's hard for
them to find those movies because
they're looking for movies about adults
not about kids but this one takes place
at a motel sort of all in the shadow of
Walt Disney World and it's about these
kids who are raised by single mothers
who are hustling it week-to-week trying
to stay afloat and he's got these great
you know no-name performances in it
Willem Dafoe is really the only actor
and he's nominated for a Best Supporting
Actor Golden Globe and it he's the mote
the motel manager in the film a little
girl in that Brooklyn prints another
overlooked performance she is fantastic
in it but yeah you don't know any one of
the girls in this film was discovered in
a target shopping laughs the director
was like yeah I want you in this movie
the mothers like get away from me I'm
calling security
all right been talking a lot this year
about Wonder Woman but people did not
talk that much about professor Marston
and though Wonder Woman
yeah well Wonder Woman the character has
the craziest origin story for like a
comic book character professor Marston
he created her he also created a
lie-detector machine he is a guy who was
married to two women and it was these
two women who created who inspired
Wonder Woman Rebecca Hall one of those
women really great another overlooked
performance she's a fantastic actress
that's her right there and I think she
this is not going to be her year at the
Oscars but her year is coming because
she is too good to not know I love this
list Eric everyone needs to be good save
this segment make the list watch all the
movies Eric Davis thinks is always buddy
love